This has been my new favorite late night snack.
I usually do sweet ones, but this is a little bit more savory.
I roasted this purple sweet potato,
and I love having it with kimchi,
so this is what I do. I roasted my sweet potato for about 45 minutes,
and then I got it out the oven,
peeled it, and I made this kimchi a while ago,
so I just been eating out of this big jar,
and I love the combination of this sweet potato with savory kimchi,
so I usually just take a little bit,
I peel my sweet potato,
put some kimchi on it, and just snack on this.
It's way past my bedtime. I shouldn't even be up.
It's past 12 right now, but I just needed a little midnight snack.
My favorite pieces of kimchi are the ones that are the leafy ones,
not the hard ones.
Mm hmm.
These are so sweet, they're almost caramelized.